for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so in this video i'd like to talk about
the regulation of the urea cycle and the
recycle hat is both regulated under sort
of long-term regulation as well as
short-term regulation so let's start
with the long term long term regulation
is based on nitrogen flux which is
basically substrate availability what I
mean by that is I'm talking about how
much nitrogen or specifically how much
ammonium ion is coming to the urea cycle
over time because the whole point of the
urea cycle is to take that ammonium ion
and sort of process it detoxify it put
it into urea and excrete it safely right
so long term the activity of the urea
cycle is gonna be based on how much
nitrogen is actually going to be
processed if there is an increase in
nitrogen flux what's going to happen is
there's going to be an increase in the
synthesis of urea cycle enzymes in the
liver and that of course will increase
urea production and when I say the
increase increased synthesis of urea
cycle enzymes I'm talking about
ornithine transcarbamylase our genus
sucks in a synthetase Argento sucks an
ace Arjun ace and of course camel
phosphate and to taste one or cps one
these are the enzymes that are involved
in the urea cycle so as more nitrogen
comes to the urea cycle or more ammonium
ions coming to the awreeoh cycle to be
processed that will may basically cause
the the increase in synthesis of these
enzymes so we have more enzymes around
so that we can process that ammonium ion
more and produce more urea and of course
the opposite is true is that if there's
a decrease in nitrogen flux there's
going to be a decrease in the synthesis
of the urea cycle enzymes in the liver
and thus will have a decrease in your
production because we won't be producing
as much yareta urea if there's not a lot
of NH 4 plus to be processed and turned
into
yuria so how as far as the long-term
regulation how would what would happen
if there was a high-protein diet there's
a high protein diet there's a large
intake of amino acids and lots of
nitrogen so there's a lot of nitrogen a
lot of ammonium ions gonna go to the
urea cycle and so there should be an
increase in the production of these
enzymes and producing more urea increase
urea synthesis the opposite would be
true for a low protein diet there's less
nitrogen flux less nitrogen coming to
the urea cycle to be processed there's
gonna be less serious and assists now
how would that work with starvation well
under starvation conditions there are no
carbohydrates or fats to be used for
energy the body taps on muscle protein
and so if it's catabolized muscle
protein there's going to be a lot of
ammonium ion that results from that and
that needs to be processed and turned
into urea so there's an increase in urea
synthesis during starvation conditions
okay so that's pretty much it for
long-term regulation what about
short-term okay as far as short-term
regulation it's basically the allosteric
regulation of the committed step
specifically the cps one step by a mile
phosphate and the taste one which of
course takes the bicarbonate or carbon
dioxide and ammonium ion and turns it
into carbon oil phosphate with the help
of two ATP's
now this enzyme is stimulated it is
activated by a regulator called n acetyl
CUDA mate what is ns ido glutamate well
if you look at the portion sort of drawn
in white here that portion is just the
amino acid glutamate so that's where
that portion of the name comes from the
glutamate just comes from the fact that
soluta made the n acetyl basically we
have an acetyl group here shown in brown
and acetyl that acetyl group is attached
to
glutamates nitrogen it's a its amino
nitrogen
hence the name and nacido glutamate now
apparently this molecule exists in
mammals pretty much exclusively to
activate cps 1 okay so what's the deal
with this thing why is this thing active
ACPs 1 and how is it made
well it's made from acetyl co a and
glutamate basically what happens is that
acetyl co is acetyl group is what ends
up being attached to the nitrogen of
glutamate and this coenzyme a ends up
leaving that reaction is catalyzed by an
acetyl of glutamate it sent the tape oh
sorry and as you don't go to make
synthase not synthetase synthase or nags
and this enzyme is actually activated by
arginine so what's the deal with that
why would that make sense
how does arginines activation of Nags
make sense well if arginine is
activating the production of NS you to
blue to mate you can kind of think about
it by extension that arginine is kind of
stimulating a buildup of Argentines kind
of stimulating CP s1 if it's if arginine
is stimulating the production of the
activator of the committed step of the
urea cycle that means basically that
high amounts of arginine are stimulating
cps 1 right not directly but indirectly
so the way i think about it is lots of
arginine or arginine amino acid if
there's lots of arginine around it
indicates a high amount of amino acids
around and that would make sense if a
high amount of amino acids are around
you would want if you're processing them
processing processing the nitrogen from
them it would make sense that a high
amount of amino acids would stimulate
the urea cycle ok so that's kind of
what's going on here lots of arginine
indicates high amount of amino acid it's
high amount of amino acids stimulating
or activating the committed enzyme ok I
hope that makes sense I hope that video
was helpful thank you for watching if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
share with
friends thank you and happy studying